thousands of police departments used
canines to keep us safe these highly
trained dogs work alongside law
enforcement and are often sent into
extremely dangerous situations but many
lack the protection they deserve that's
where a 10 year old boy from Ohio has
stepped up and has already raised more
than a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars I was watching the so called
life PD and there's his canine that
didn't have a vest so I wanted a vest
him yeah I love that yeah she's sweet at
8 years old at the time and his step
that's a police officer so he knows the
importance of the Kevlar vest yeah I
didn't even pick up that the dog wasn't
wearing one he turned to me and was like
what's going on in to this date that's
when he started Brady's canine fun and
he's raised over 130,000 and how many of
you vested how many dogs 127 these bets
are custom-made for the canines and they
don't get like overheated they're
specifically kind of yeah it's a whole
new technology that they're rolling out
they're protective of just their vital
organs allows them have full movement
which is super important yeah and police
departments rely on donations for these
vessels be not in the budget yeah yeah
budget for canines is really low it's
like being a teacher
okay so you've recently received a big
honor as well right yeah so ASPCA told
me that I'm the kid of the year
I was proud that they picked me yeah
that's so cool it's cuz you're dude what
were y'all doing at nine and ten I
wouldn't sound the way I was I was
eating like I don't know if I did
anything that cool that is you've got
such a big heart I have the years crazy
yeah how would you know that existed to
be a kid of the year that's huge brother
I know and we didn't know it exists
because we weren't offered that most
recent recipient of events from Brady's
canine fund is my tow from the Hawthorne
Police Department here in California
he's here actually with his handler
officer Sarah Lewis y'all come on
[Applause]
okay because he's allergic to dogs okay
oh my toes the star start like you know
getting in hives I want him to come back
to my show much different I mean I wear
vests from here to protect my vital
organs so this is this is amazing and
this best in particular is really nice
because it's lighter weight so the dogs
I I can put this on my toe and keep him
in my car and because you never know
sometimes if I contact a suspect and
they run and they're armed I have a door
pop right here on my belt and I can pop
him out he's already got his protection
on ready to go and I feel better about
it and he's safe this week the Cirque
Dreams kicked off their annual holidays
show coming to nearly 60 cities from
coast to coast
here to tell us about this year's tour
please welcome Broadway producer and
Cirque Dreams founder neil goldberg it's
become one cuz it's so cute it has its
twelfth year sixty cities I mean this
show has something in it for everyone
and that's why people keep going back to
see it yeah and all over the United
States you can see it in the Fabulous
Fox theatres in Atlanta yeah and and in
st. Louis from Denver Philadelphia
Charlotte Connecticut Oh everywhere yeah
every one we keep going back because
it's a great tradition cuz you know I
grew up in New York and my mom and dad
used to take us into the city to see the
Radio City Christmas Spectacular and
what I remember was a kid was that
amazing feeling of mom and dad taking
the kids in the grandparents and going
to see something about the holidays that
everyone can share and it almost like
kicks off the season for you but gets
you in like the spirit of everything I
love it it does and you know I also love
when people walk out of the theater and
sometimes I'll meet them in the lobby
and I'll say so how did you think about
the show and they go I just want to go
out and start shopping and oh yeah and
the show you know you hear the word circ
so yeah there's all that amazing
acrobatic audacity and trapeze and
flying but this is all about the holiday
season every one of the 20 scenes in
this two-hour show tell another story
penguins North Pole snowing skiing toy
soldiers walking on thin wires so we've
taken all of these amazing things that
people have seen in these searches in
Vegas and on television yeah and we've
steamed them to the holiday so and
you're breaking into the masses and it's
for families like it's not just for
adults like its everybody can come
that's what I love it is it is the
adults worry about you know parking we
worry about stroller parking but Neal
brought some of his performers who are
ready to give us a show let's see it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I thought for sure one was gonna drop I
was I mean I that's like you hitting a
bad note I do you don't want you going
you'll impress them later you have
something special though for Brady and
Lea right I do
I'm personally for on behalf of Cirque
Dreams
we are so proud of what you have done
and like we said the show is playing in
60 cities but our biggest show is going
to be in Colorado and everyone at Cirque
Dreams wanted me to represent to you and
your mom and dad that you're going to
come and see that show surgeries
holidays is performing 60 shows at the
brand-new Gaylord Rockies resort in
Colorado and the hotel is flying Brady
and his parents to the resort where
they'll attend a performance as VIPs but
that's not all
Cirque Dreams holidays is also
performing here at the Dolby Theatre in
Los Angeles and everyone in my audience
is getting
[Applause]
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this